nicht nur unser körpereigenes
Immunsystem ist gefordert Ziel Corona
sondern auch unsere politischen
ökonomischen und sozialen Abwehrkräfte
sie Russlands Überfall auf die Ukraine
diese Abwehrkräfte sind massiv unter
Beschuss und das Gefährte die Stabilität
in unserem Land
Inflation und Energiekrise was hält
unsere Wirtschaft aus jetzt in der
Phönix Runde
Phoenix Runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
verena hupperts ist bei uns von der
SPD-Bundestagsabgeordnete
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
zuständig für Wirtschaftsbau wohnen und
Tourismus und diese Zuständigkeit kommen
sich von ungefähr sie waren früher
Unternehmerin haben ein ziemlich
legendäres Start-up gegründet kitchen
Stories eine kochplattform mit insgesamt
20 Millionen Downloads
livecolm von der AFD ebenfalls
Bundestagsabgeordneter ebenfalls
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitzende
auch zuständig für Wirtschaft und
wirtschaftspolitischer Sprecher der
Bundestagsfraktion an die Höning ist
Leiterin der Wirtschaftsredaktion der
Rheinischen Post
und Professor Marcel Fratscher Präsident
des Deutschen Instituts für
Wirtschaftsforschung DIW Herr Fratzscher
was bedeuten denn bedeutet das was heute
Robert Habeck in der sogenannten
Herbstprojektion also der Voraussage für
die nächsten Monate in Sachen Wirtschaft
von sich gegeben hat konzentrieren wir
uns vielleicht erstmal auf die
Privathaushalte wie eng Finanz wie eng
finanziell wird es eigentlich für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in dem Fall im
nächsten Jahr
wir warten eine Rezession wir sind
wahrscheinlich schon jetzt in der
wirtschaftlichen Rezession es wird sich
auch nächstes Jahr als mindest im ersten
Halbjahr fortsetzen die Zahlen klingen
jetzt erstmal nicht dramatisch und
schrumpfen von -0,4 Prozent der
Wirtschaft ist relativ moderat im
Vergleich zu dem was wir am Anfang in
der corona-pandemie hatten aber es sind
zwei große Risiken dabei das erste ist
es kann viel schief gehen wenn es zu
einer Knappheit im Winter von Gas kommt
wenn es eine Eskalation des Krieges gibt
wenn Unternehmen Schieflage kommen
könnte diese Rezession viel tiefer
ausfallen und das zweite was diese Zahl
nicht zeigen ist ist die Verteilung der
Kosten extremst und ungleich ist es
trifft kleine mittlere Unternehmen sehr
viel härter und vor allem trefft es
Menschen mit geringen Einkommen viel
viel härter weil diese Menschen die
individuell eine viel höhere Inflation
haben sie müssen viel mehr ihres
monatlichen Einkommens für die Dinge
ausgeben die teurer geworden sind also
Energie Nahrungsmittel und wir haben 40%
der deutschen die kein Rücklagen keine
Ersparnisse haben
die also mit dieser Krise nicht umgehen
können und also so gesehen klingen die
Zahlen erst einmal nicht so schlimm aber
für einzelne Gruppen sind sie wirklich
dramatisch Robert die hohen Preise für
Energie machen ja nicht nur privat
Leuten sorgen sondern vor allen Dingen
auch vielen Betrieben immer mehr
Insolvenzen drohen diese Entwicklung hat
ja schon eingesetzt ist die Ampel
wirklich auf dem besten Weg die
schlimmsten Härten für die Wirtschaft
abzumildern abzufedern
wir müssen zwei Dinge tun auf der einen
Seite müssen wir jetzt in der Krise ganz
akut unterstützen und das tun wir wir
haben jetzt schon mehr als drei
entlastungspakete auf den Weg gebracht
wir haben jetzt wirklich mit dem
Abwehrschirm auch richtig was dabei für
die kleinen und mittleren aber auch die
Großindustrie aber wir müssen natürlich
jetzt auch dafür sorgen dass wir die
Zukunft aufbauen damit danach noch in
dem Land auch was zu transformieren
bleibt und ja wir nehmen die Sorgen sehr
ernst und wir werden auch mit
härteverlösungen und Co das Wort des
Bundeskanzlers gilt wir lassen niemanden
in dieser Krise alleine und dafür
kämpfen wir dafür setzen wir uns ein
dafür bringen wir jetzt auch diesen
Abwehrschirm auf den Weg inwieweit der
Wirkung zeigt das wollen wir noch im
Laufe der Sendung vertiefener Holm ich
bin heute auf ihrer Website über einen
Satz gestolpert hängen geblieben sie
sagten nämlich dass Energiepaket der
Ampel sei ein Schritt in die richtige
Richtung
also doch keine total Opposition was ja
eigentlich ihre Partei und
Fraktionsführung angekündigt hat wir
machen immer vernünftige Sacharbeit wie
sich das gehört und es ist natürlich ein
notwendig dass wir in dieser Situation
besonders diejenigen ja unterstützen die
jetzt unter diesen Energiepreisen und
der Energieknappheit leiden nur eins ist
auch wichtig wir können uns nicht immer
wieder mit der Symptom herum doktorei
beschäftigen oder wir müssen an die
Ursachen heran und da geht unsere
Generalkritik an die Ampel das sie ist
nicht schafft hätte ich schon längst
machen können dafür zu sorgen dass das
Energieangebot massiv ausgeweitet wird
dass alle Kraftwerkskapazitäten ans Netz
kommen um damit auch die Strompreise zu
senken und damit auch Linderung
möglichst schnell zu schaffen Frau
Höning sie schreiben dass es nicht die
Aufgabe des Staates sein kann jeden
Betrieb durch die Rezession zu bringen
wir sollten uns nicht zu Tode retten
selbst wenn wir uns nicht zu Tode retten
trotzdem wird er viele werden viele
Verlierer übrig bleiben in dieser
möglichen Rezession die uns jetzt
bevorsteht ja das ist eine Krise
unerhörten Ausmaßes und der
Sachverständigenrat bzw die
Forschungsinstitute haben ja vor einigen
Wochen auch schon den Blick dahin
gerichtet was passiert wenn es richtig
schlimm wird dann haben wir eine
Rezession von bis zu acht Prozent also
was weit mehr ist als das was Herr
harberg heute für nächstes Jahr voraus
sagt wenn es richtig schlimm kommt und
darum ist es wichtig das zu verhindern
aber eben mit dem richtigen Instrument
aber wenn wir gleich noch viel darüber
sprechen über die Unsinnigkeit der
gaspreisbremse aber zurück zu ihrer
Frage der Staat kann nicht alle Betriebe
retten hat schon in der coronakrise
viele Betriebe gerettet die jetzt mit
einem kaputten Geschäftsmodell dastehen
das ist total bitter für den Einzelnen
aber solche Rezessionen haben dann auch
immer eine reinigende Wirkung und ich
wenn natürlich keine Namen aber wir alle
haben Vorstellungen
von Unternehmen in Innenstädten wo wir
sagen deren Geschäftsmodell hat sich
einfach überholt jetzt haben sie uns ja
schon wissen lassen was sie von der
gaspreisbremse erhalten wenn ich jetzt
das aufnehme was ich sagen die Frage ist
ja auch inwieweit der Staat Geld in die
Hand nehmen muss um Wirtschafts zu
stabilisieren das war ja auch ein
wesentliches Element der Bewältigung der
corona-pandemie das heißt wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe geht's weniger um
zusätzlich Staatsausgaben also nicht so
viel doppelwumms sondern eine
Ausgabenbremse um die Verschuldung nicht
ins Uferlose steigen zu lassen ja die
Schulden sind das eine Thema wobei ich
es da vollkommen richtig finde was die
Ampel da macht jetzt richtig viel Geld
in die Hand nehmen mich stört nicht die
Höhe es ist ja auch weit weniger als wir
gehört zur Bank für die Bankenkrise
ausgegeben haben weit weniger als für
Corona damit habe ich kein Problem
ehrlich machen Schuldenbremse ist da
noch auch wieder ein anderes Thema aber
der Weg gaspreisbremse der ist der
falsche weil der Staat soll nicht an den
Preisen herum er soll den
Marktmechanismus wirken lassen damit das
Preissignal ankommt bei den Betrieben
und Haushalten damit sie sparen die
Industrie hat es ja zum Teil schon
gemacht die privaten Haushalte haben es
noch fast gar nicht gemacht das gute
Wetter hat es bisher auch nicht verlangt
aber das ist ein Problem sogar die
gaskommission hat ja noch mal bekräftigt
der Gasverbrauch muss 20 Prozent runter
sonst schaffen wir es nicht die
Gasspeicher alleine reichen nicht aus um
uns durch den Winter zu bringen aber
Herr Holm bin in der Markt das regeln
soll ist es ja möglicherweise in einer
solchen
Krisensituationen der falsche Weg der
Stadt muss ja irgendwo auch
Wirtschaftspolitik betreiben er muss ja
auch Steuern er kann das ja nicht alles
im freien Spiel der Kräfte überlassen
naja man sollte dafür sorgen dass der
Markt funktionieren kann und seinen Weg
geht also ich stimme Frau Höning da im
Grunde ja schon zu das ist nicht
sinnvoll ist in den Preismechanismus
einzugreifen nur wir haben eine derart
schwere Krise das ist jetzt glaube ich
geboten ist wenn nicht lese das Deutsche
Bank research war es glaube ich
geschrieben hat von zehn Jahren
vielleicht auf diese Zeit schauen werden
und werden sagen das war der Anfang der
Industrialisierung unseres Landes und
zum massiv ist es schon also wir ich
habe den Eindruck dass wir das den Ernst
der Lage manchmal noch nicht so richtig
erkennen wir müssen da jetzt schon rein
und der Staat gaspreisbremse ist
natürlich ein schwieriges Instrument
aber ich denke es ist für eine
Überbrückung zwar notwendig wenn gleich
wir sagen wenn wir direkt an die
Ursachen gehen würden und die
Möglichkeiten wären ja da also die
Kraftwerke sind ja da die wir ans Netz
bringen können warum läuft das dritte
Kernkraftwerk nicht weiter es gibt dafür
keine keine wirkliche Begründung wir
haben den bundesnetzagentur-chef im
Wirtschaftsausschuss gehabt ich habe ihn
das mehrfach gefragt hat erst gar nicht
drauf geantwortet Warum das dritte nicht
dann kam auf nochmaliges insistieren die
Antwort die gebe ich lieber diese
Antwort an das Ministerium ab also es
gibt offensichtlich kein triftigen Grund
dafür und das ist der der generalsweg
zur zur Bewältigung dieser Krise ich
würde auf den Energiemix kommen wir noch
den richtigen Frau Hubert
es geht ja um wie viel Geld der Staat in
die Hand um zu stützen er hat ja schon
sehr viel bei der Bekämpfung der
corona-pandemie und der wirtschaftlichen
Folgen getan ist da nicht irgendwo mal
die Grenze erreicht was kann man da tun
eine SPD Politikerin wird sicherlich
auch mit wirtschaftssteuerung was
anfangen können aber diese 200
Milliarden ist das jetzt sozusagen das
letzte Wort danach geht nichts mehr nein
also wir fahren ja jetzt auch in dieser
Krise ganz akutaufsicht weil wir jetzt
ja alle auch noch nicht wissen wie wird
das nächste Jahr und wir gehen ja davon
aus der nächste Winter wird ähnlich hart
oder härter und es kann ja jetzt nicht
sein dass wir sagen jetzt lassen wir
halt einfach mal die Wirtschaft hops
gehen und ich stimme Ihnen da nicht zu
wir haben da Unternehmen die hatten eine
Gasrechnung von 12.000 Euro im Monat
kleine Mittelständler die haben jetzt
eine diesen über 100.000 da kann ich ja
nicht sagen Pech gehabt und dann machen
wir jetzt hier mal alles dicht und was
uns das kostet wenn wir jetzt in
Massenarbeitslosigkeit und in das kommen
wenn die Industrie einmal weg ist und
wir sehen ja was immer über den Atlantik
passiert die Amerikaner die werden
massiv an und da müssen wir doch jetzt
zusammenhalten und die Arbeitsplätze
schützen denn das kostet uns im zweiten
dritten vierten runden nachher viel viel
mehr und deswegen die 200 Milliarden die
werden die Reichen jetzt erstmal die
sind auch wirklich ein doppelter
Abwehrschirm aber wir werden alle noch
nicht wissen können wie diese Krise
ausgeht wie dieser Krieg ausgeht und
deswegen gilt dieses Versprechen wir
lassen auch die wirtschaftlich in sich
in Stich ich wollte kein Unternehmen
hops gehen lassen es ist richtig dass
sie das Geld auf den Tisch legen der Weg
ist nur der falsche sie müssen das Geld
nehmen und den Bedürftigen Haushalten
wie Betrieben gezielt helfen was sie
jetzt machen ist mit der Gießkanne durch
das Land gehen und Hilfen Verteilen von
der gaspreisbremse produziert
profitieren die Haushalte am meisten die
den höchsten Gasverbrauch haben Willen
mit Schwimmbädern hat heute noch die
Hans-Böckler-Stiftung das
Forschungsinstitut des
gewerkschaftsnahen der
gewerkschaftsnahen Stiftung ausgerechnet
da wundere ich mich wieso die SPD eine
solche
gaspreisbremse mit trägt viel besser
wäre es wenn man das Geld nimmt um den
wirklich Bedürftigen helfen das gilt für
den kleinen Handwerker für den mittleren
Mittelständler und natürlich für die
ganzen Haushalte was weit mehr als
Hartz-IV-Haushalte sind es geht aber
auch um die Großindustrie und Gas wird
halt eben in der Wirtschaft eingesetzt
und wir müssen den Betrieben helfen und
wir sagen ja auch ihr müsst sparen also
da ist ja auch der Spar ein Reiz in
dieser gaspreisbremse mit drin 20 30
Prozent je nachdem in welcher Kategorie
das Unternehmen zugeordnet ist und
deswegen ist das ein sinnhafter weg und
auch ein praktikablerweg denn natürlich
hätten wir jetzt alle noch die
Kommission ein paar mehr Wochen Tagen
lassen können aber die Lösung die muss
ja jetzt schnell umgesetzt werden und
sie wird nicht unbedingt besser indem
man noch mal guckt wer steckt denn
hinter welchem Gasanschluss können wir
nämlich gar nicht weil in Deutschland
auch die Daten fehlen wir kommen ja aus
einer Zeit von viel zu langer Kroko und
von viel zu lang einfach auch diese
Erneuerbaren nicht ausgebaut und uns
viel zu abhängig auch gemacht in dieser
Situation und das ist jetzt wirklich
eine schnelle Hilfe die wir maximal mit
Wumms auf die Strecke bringen nicht
vergessen das aber zur groko ja unter
anderem auch die noch nie gehört habe
werden die Rechnung nicht gemacht damals
noch mit den Strommengen und Co
bevor wir jetzt dieses ganze
Konfliktpotential ansprechen dass die
Energiepreis die gaspreisbremse andere
Preis Bremsen und die Energie Knappheit
mit sich bringt noch etwas
Grundsätzliches
Ratscher die Prognosen des
Internationalen Währungsfonds für die
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung fallen für
Deutschland ganz besonders düster aus
also ein wirtschaftlicher Riese
eigentlich im weltweiten Maßstab woran
liegt das eigentlich
das liegt an der Struktur unserer
Wirtschaft dass wir in dieser Krise in
vielen Krisen sehr viel härter betroffen
sind es liegt daran dass wir relativ
hohen Anteil von energieintensiven
Unternehmen haben obwohl wir keine
eigenen Energieträger erneuerbare jetzt
aber fossile kaum haben es liegt auch an
der Struktur dass wir dann auch sehr
offenen Volkswirtschaft sind wir sehr im
globalen Wettbewerb stehen und dieser
Schock den wir jetzt gerade erleben ist
asymmetrisch natürlich steigen überall
die Energiepreise aber nirgendsstärker
als in Europa und nirgends stärker als
in Deutschland das heißt ein Unternehmen
das in Deutschland im Wettbewerb mit dem
koreanischen chinesischen amerikanischen
Unternehmen steht hat ein riesigen
Wettbewerbsnachteil weil dort die
Energiepreise eben bei weitem nicht so
stark gestiegen sind und das ist auch
kein temporäres Problem sondern das ist
ein permanenter Schock also auch in zwei
drei Jahren werden wir nie wieder zu den
Preisen vor der Krise zurückkommen
deshalb ist die die Fehler die wir vor
zehn vor 15 Jahren begangen haben gerade
auch 2014 nach der schon der Krim dass
wir uns nicht nur sehenden Auges in eine
immer stärkere Abhängigkeit Russlands
begeben haben sondern das über sieben
auch gesagt haben wir haben die
Energiewende verschlafen wir haben den
Ausbau erneuerbarer Energien verschlafen
wenn wir heute bei 80 90 Prozent
Energieproduktion durch erneuerbare
wären hätten wir dieses Problem bei
weitem nicht das heißt wir müssen jetzt
in höchster Geschwindigkeit das Aufholen
was wir in den letzten 10 15 Jahren
verschlafen haben schnellen Umstieg auf
erneuerbaren Energien und die
technologische Transformation also der
einzige Weg wie die Unternehmen im
Wettbewerb stehen können also wie wir
diese Struktur diesen Wohlstand sichern
können ist denn eben die technologische
Transformation zu neuen effizienten
Technologien gelingt und das ist eine
gigantische Herausforderung die riesige
öffentliche und private Investition
erfordert Wohlstand schon angesprochen
räumen sie sind ja in einer
beneidenswerten Situation sind der
Opposition sie können viel fordern
müssen die politische Verantwortung
dafür nicht übernehmen aber ist es nicht
nötig den Menschen in dieser Situation
die ja außer ziemlich schwierig ist zu
sagen dass sie tatsächlich auch
Wohlstandsverluste über längere Zeit
hinnehmen müssen ich meine nicht die die
sowieso nichts haben es geht um es geht
ja um eine Aufteilung der Kosten und die
unterstützen und müssen die unterstützen
die
praktisch bedingungslos auf Hilfe
angewiesen sind aber muss man den
anderen nicht sagen dass es zu diesen
Wohlstandsverlusten vorübergehend oder
vielleicht auch für längere Zeit führen
wird das ist die dramatische Wahrheit
die man sagen muss es wird diese
Wohlstandsverluste geben nichts anderes
ist ja das BIP was wir jetzt sehen fürs
nächste Jahr was eben noch sehr positiv
ausgedrückt wird mit einer leichten
Rezession aber Frau Höning hat ja schon
gesagt wenn die gasmangelage kommt und
mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit wird sie
kommen wie sich das abzeichnet es ist
seitdem wir haben ganz milden Winter
vielleicht aber die wird wahrscheinlich
kommen und dann haben wir eben eine
dramatisch Rezession die die von der
Finanzkrise noch übertrifft was mir noch
wichtig ist wir müssen auch die Analyse
natürlich richtig stellen ich stimme
Herrn Fratzscher überhaupt nicht dazu in
der in der Aufnahme des Befundes dass
wir die Erneuerbaren jetzt noch weiter
vorantreiben müssten denn die ist das
Problem ich habe das Gefühl uns wird
erzählt nimmt noch mehr von der Medizin
die euch krank gemacht hat ich habe ja
nichts dagegen wenn wir eine beinengung
haben auch an Photovoltaik und an
Windkraftanlagen aber wir können darauf
nicht ein Industrieland von der Größe in
Deutschlands aufbauen das funktioniert
nicht weil wir die Grundlast gar nicht
gewährleisten können das ist das
Grundproblem was wir haben einer
Energiewende die seit 20 Jahren völlig
gegen den Baum läuft und deswegen sind
stehen wir so schlecht da jetzt auch in
den internationalen Daten viel
schlechter als alle anderen wir haben
uns weil wir Kernkraft weil wir Kohle
abschalten abhängig vom Gas gemacht ist
und das fällt uns jetzt dermaßen auf die
Füße dass wir jetzt die Umkehr endlich
finden müssten aber
das geht ja dann auch im Wasser und das
können Sie sich jetzt irgendwo herholen
zu investieren und da sind Wasserstoff
investieren ich bin auch eher skeptisch
aufgestellt ob das die Lösung sein kann
es kann so doch heute nicht
funktionieren wir müssen den Menschen
doch heute helfen und wir sehen dass wir
in eine falsche Richtung marschiert sind
vor 20 Jahren haben sie die Energiewende
angefangen unter Rot-Grün bis heute
funktioniert das mit dem Wasserstoff
überhaupt nicht wo ist er denn in
massiver Verwendung
Thema also und die Energiewende ist ja
wohl alternativlos als gemeinschaftliche
Aufgabe anerkennen dass wir unseren
Planeten retten wollen es muss nur
richtig und schnell gehen und da ist man
ja auch auf dem Weg wir müssen auch bei
den Fakten bleiben die Fakten sind
erneuerbare Energien sind deutlich
günstiger als Atomkraft vor allem als
Atomkraft oder fossile Energieträger das
ist Fakt und wenn wir einen schnelleren
Ausbau erneuerbare Energien gehabt
hätten hätten wir heute deutlich
geringere Kosten für Energie nicht
höhere Kosten deshalb ist der Weg ein
schnellere Energiewende ein schnellerer
Ausbau erneuerbarer Energien damit wir
aus der Abhängigkeit von fossilen
Energieträgern kommen
SPD und Grünen zu Gast sind immer wieder
das muss jetzt forschiert werden das ist
ja auch Bestandteil des
Koalitionsvertrags nur bis das wirksam
ist nämlich eine Ausweitung
regenerativer Energien vor allen Dingen
solar- und Wind selbst oder günstigsten
Bedingungen dauert das noch Jahre bis
dahin muss ja eine Art
Brückentechnologie da sein um diese
großen Grundlast sicherzustellen also du
hast die Versorgungssicherheit ist das
nicht auch muss man nicht zweigleisig
fahren einerseits das zwar als
politisches Ziel anstreben so wie das im
Koalitionsvertrag festgelegt worden ist
aber andererseits auch dafür sorgen dass
noch genügend so wenig beliebt das bei
manchen ist genügend fossile
Energieträger da sind und das passiert
ja es wird ja beispielsweise über
Flüssiggases kommen jetzt zwei
lng-terminals kommt zwei im kommenden
Jahr dazu man hat mit Qatar Abkommen
gemacht ab 2025 mehr fossile
Energieträger also LNG zu bekommen das
tut man ja aber auch da gehört zur
Wahrheit zu du das ist deutlich teurer
als was wir bisher gehabt haben das wird
nie wieder die die Preise für Energie
für Gas auf das wo kriegen was vor der
Krise hatten also man muss der
Wirtschaft den Unternehmen den Menschen
rein Wein einschenken die Energie wird
nicht wieder so günstig sein wie sie mal
vor der Krise war bis wir wirklich die
Erneuerbaren ausreichen ausgebaut haben
und da haben sie völlig recht das wird
fünf bis zehn Jahre dauern bis wir ein
so starken Ausbau haben dass die Preise
auch wieder anfangen können zu sinken
und so weit gehört auch dass man sagt
Gas bleibt eine Brückentechnologie wir
können noch nicht ohne Gas ohne dieses
grundlastproblem weil wir das lösen
müssen und solange wir noch nicht genug
Wasserstoff haben was in Zukunft
ökologisch neutralia herzustellen ist
werden wir auch weiter Gasimporte aus
der ganzen Welt haben müssen und
sinnvollerweise nicht mehr von
russischen Unterstützung auf die
Wirtschaft dabei wie werden wir
effizienter nämlich wie nutzen wir jetzt
die Fernwärme die Abwärme wie gehen wir
mal an eine großwärmepumpe an der
kommunale wärmeplanung ran also wir
müssen uns jetzt wirklich anstrengen
damit alles so maximal effizient
miteinander vernetzt genutzt wird wie es
auch nur geht und ja Gas ist unsere
Brücke die Brücke ist jetzt weggefallen
nicht nur das russische Gasthaus
weggefallen aber in großen Teilen war
eben das russische Gas unser
hauptgas-lieferant und deswegen müssen
wir es jetzt woanders herbekommen mit
den Energy und wir haben jetzt noch das
Biogas jetzt zu Hause beschleunigt in
der Welt wir sehen doch dass wir eine
ganz andere Richtung laufen als die
Länder um uns herum die Bilder die
Franzosen verlängern Laufzeiten bauen
neue Kernkraftwerke bei den Amerikanern
bekommen wir den französischen Atomstrom
dann wieder wenn wir der dunkelflaute
haben also wie gehen da in die falsche
Richtung das kann so nicht funktionieren
wir brauchen eine Sicherheit auf diese
Sicherheit muss man aufbauen konnte
darum geht es auch den Unternehmen die
brauchen die Sicherheit spielen ganz
andere Länder setzen auch ganz stark auf
Ökostrom und wenn es um Umweltschutz
geht dann sind doch Kernkräfte
Kernkraftwerke das Beste was man
überhaupt machen kann
ausnahmsweise mal bei Greta Thunberg die
das genau gesagt hat es ist ja richtig
es ist richtig das sind CO2
emissionsfrei ist das Lösung Technologie
eine Brückentechnologie die wir eine
Weile brauchen werden wie es andere
Länder eben auch machen wir vereinen
damit die Ziele Umweltschutz
gewährleisten und Energiesicherheit zu
günstigen Preis damit kommen wir dann
auch klar Herr Holm wenn wir in Zukunft
anders als das in ihrer Partei ja
gefordert wird dauerhaft auf russisches
Gas verzichten das könnten wir dann
irgendwann tun das können wir jetzt im
Moment nicht das müssen wir uns auch
klar machen weil wir sehen ja diese
Gaspreise die durch die Decke gehen das
ist ja das große Problem dass wir zu
wenig für ein Land das sich zwischen Gas
gemacht habe in ihrer Partei wieder die
Forderung erhoben nach trinkt 1 und 2
wieder zu aktivieren beide Gasleitungen
sind ja geöffnet nur an den falschen
Stellen sie sind nicht beschädigt worden
nachdem was ich da gehört habe ist wenn
überhaupt zu reparieren nur in den
langen Zeitraum und vor allen Dingen
wäre es ja etwas wie eine Kapitulation
vor Putin wenn man das wieder aktivieren
will also das halte ich für falsch
natürlich müssen wir diese Dinge mit
Bedenken aus dem politischer Art das ist
keine Frage nur wir sehen andere Länder
ja auch dass sie weiterhin russisches
Gas beziehen das sind die Italiener
beispielsweise die damit überhaupt kein
Problem haben die Österreicher Leidens
durch und wir sollten das auch weiter
tun ich erinnere daran dass auch der
Bundeskanzler Scholz ja mehr Gas haben
wollte aus Nordstemmen eins da gab es
die politischen Spielchen aus Moskau
okay aber im Prinzip wollte er für
Deutschland das Gas ja weiterhin haben
und wenn das jetzt über Natrium 1 nicht
geht kann man es doch probieren über
Nord Stream 2 ein Strang soll ja in
Ordnung sein putin wird als
Gegenleistung die Aufhebung von
Sanktionen fordern das wäre doch erst
recht die Kapitulation nicht nur vor
Putin sondern
an dem Punkt sind wir noch nicht das ist
jetzt Spekulation dass das kommen würde
aber wir sollten es zumindest probieren
weil wir im Moment einfach so abhängig
sind von diesem Gas ist einfach brauchen
und LNG ist nicht die Lösung der
Bundeskanzler hat jetzt ein Schiff LNG
mitgebracht von seiner Reise Katar das
ist eine halbtages-leistung von Nord
Stream also wir haben aber 370 halbe
Tage im Jahr also so kann es nicht
funktionieren also da muss ich ja
widersprechen wenn sie jetzt sagen nur
zu den zwei aufmachen dann macht sich
Deutschland zum Handlanger Putins es ist
vollkommen richtig dass Deutschland da
nicht aus den Sanktionen des Westens
ausschert und wenn wir uns darauf
verständigt haben dass wir nicht in den
Krieg Eingreifen mit Soldaten und den
nato-verlauf beschwören ist es ja wohl
richtig dass der Westen da zusammen
steht und wirtschaftlich klare Kante
zeigt und wenn sie jetzt sagen 192
aufmachen dann machen sie sich auch zum
Handlanger Putins für die ganz normale
eben dann machen sie die Italiener auch
zu Handlangern und die Österreicher und
diejenigen die noch Öl beziehen
weiterhin auch da gibt es ja nur ein
freiwilliges ambargo auf deutscher Seite
andere Länder beziehen weiter russisches
Öl also da muss man auch die Kirche im
Dorf lassen und mal seine Position
überprüfen da muss man seine Position
überprüfen finden verurteilen wir
natürlich auch das ist ja völlig klar
das ist ohne Frage
in der ersten Bundestagsdebatte haben
wir das sofort markiert das eine Frage
reist und wurde jetzt in
Nordrhein-Westfalen
ja natürlich dass das gibt es das stelle
ich auch überhaupt nicht in Abrede aber
wir haben ganz klar das
Bundestagsfraktion hier gehandelt und
zwar unmittelbar nachdem der Krieg aus
aber man muss natürlich auch sagen dass
die beiden Länder diese genannt haben
Italien in Österreich sich einige
Politiker ja damit brüsten dass sie gute
Beziehungen auch zu Putin haben
vielleicht die Situation da auch etwas
anders als bei uns ich würde gerne noch
eine Flamme ans Gas halten und zwar zum
anderen Grund Stefan weil der
hochgelobte Wahlsieger von Niedersachsen
hat ja gesagt in seinem Land käme ist im
Wahlkampf in seinem Land käme es
überhaupt nicht in Frage dass dort
Fracking Gas gefördert wird gleichzeitig
hat er kein Problem aber auf
niedersächsischen Territorium einen
Flüssiggas Terminal zu errichten das mit
Flüssiggas aus Fracking vorkommenden USA
kommt wo der Fracking Gas zu wesentlich
ungünstigeren Umweltbedingungen
gefördert wird als bei uns ist das nicht
eine
doppelzügigkeit oder eine eine
Widersprüchlichkeit die er
möglicherweise auch nicht mehr so lange
jetzt nachdem er die Wahl gewonnen hat
nicht mehr so lange durchhalten kann
wir tun ja gerade viele Dinge die wir
nicht tun wollten zum Beispiel AKWs in
Reserve halten und bei Fracking ist die
Frage gar nicht ob wir es wollen oder
nicht wissen Sie wie lange das dauert
bis wir das hätten
Genehmigungsverfahren Planungsverfahren
probebogen ist ein paar Jahre im Dorf
von daher brauchen wir da gar nicht
drüber zu diskutieren und das ist für
mich genauso eine Rolle rückwärts wie
AKWs noch mal reaktivieren in der Dauer
weil wir haben andere Lösungen und die
wollen wir jetzt mit Vollgas ausbauen
muss ich Ihnen widersprechen wir
brauchen die Brücke Gas ja noch ein
bisschen länger und auch auf mittlere
Sicht brauchen wir noch weitere
Gasquellen da wäre Fracking Gas ist zu
probieren eine Möglichkeit das ist ja
besser wir Franken sauber Gas in
Deutschland als wir kaufen Fracking Gas
in der Welt ein wo es nicht so sauber
gefreckt wird
aber wir müssen doch so da für sorgen
dass das wenige Gas was wir haben dass
das zielgerichtet eingesetzt wird also
das wäre jetzt kein die Gasheizung
austauschen aber es werden andere Punkt
aber wir schließen
zu erhöhen senkt ja auch die Preise und
damit sind wir wieder beim Anfang das
würde den Verbrauchern helfen das gilt
für Strom wie für Gas wir müssen es
Angeboten darf ich dann noch mal
nachfragen sie haben das am Anfang der
Sendung gesagt sagt die Energiepreise
sind anderen Ländern viel niedriger und
damit sind die viele wettbewerbsfähiger
warum ist das eigentlich so wir werden
die da auch subventioniert
in diesen Ländern weil es gibt ja den
Vorwurf an Deutschland durch diesen
doppelwurms in Höhe von 200 Milliarden
Euro gäbe es eine Wettbewerbsverzerrung
innerhalb der Europäischen Union das
dann die Industrie anderer Länder
benachteiligt wird weil Deutschland die
eigene Industrie so peppelt machen dass
die anderen Länder nicht
das machen die anderen Länder nicht in
dem Maße vor allem außerhalb Europas
eigentlich nicht auch dort werden
fossile Energieträger genauso wie hier
massiv subventioniert aber was jetzt in
dieser Krise unterschiedlich ist nehmen
Sie die Amerikaner die haben eben
größten Teil von Gas und Ölproduktion
einheimisch das heißt was häufig teurer
wird bei teuer ist bei Energie sind die
Infrastrukturen deshalb war das Gas aus
Russland so günstig wenn man sie über
eine Pipeline beziehen konnte RNG
brauchen sie eine Technologie das zu
verflüssigen dann Tanker die das
Transportieren und dann wieder eine
Fabrik die das wieder in in gas umformt
aber das ist ein extrem teure
Infrastruktur und das haben viele andere
Länder aber viele Jahre auch in Asien
produziert geschaffen und damit eben
Zugang und auch mit langjährigen
Verträgen ähnlich wie wir das mit
Russland hatten eben über langjährige
Verträge für günstiges Gas haben die
eben mit mittleren Osten mit Ländern
Lateinamerika Verträge wie sie
langfristig günstiger Energie beziehen
können das ist der Unterschied also
einmal langfristige Verträge und eine
infrast Struktur die uns jetzt im
Prinzip weggebrochen ist mit den
Pipelines nach Russland Roberts droht
eigentlich bei uns eine die
Industrialisierung das heißt dass viele
größere Betriebe jetzt auch wegen der
hohen Energiepreise der möglicherweise
verzerrten Wettbewerbssituation ins
Ausland abwandern
ich würde noch kurz ergänzen zu
Professor Fratzscher in Frankreich haben
wir zum Beispiel industriestrompreis das
grenzt direkt auch an meinen Wahlkreis
Trier an und wir sehen wie sich das
Unternehmen dann überlegt wo denn die
Betriebsstätte aufgebaut wird und dass
man sich jetzt so viel genau natürlich
passiert das es ist ein globaler
Wettbewerb Amerika wirkt gerade in
großen Maße an und deswegen sagen wir
auch wir müssen die Industrie hier
halten weil die werden jetzt nicht die
Laptops einmal zuklappen und dann gehen
die dahin und nach der Krise kommen die
zurück wenn die Arbeitsplätze einmal weg
sind dann sind die weg und deswegen
müssen wir es hier auch langfristig
wettbewerbsfähig halten da haben wir
auch einige sym Koalitionsvertrag zum
Beispiel die
klimaschutzdifferenzverträge sehr langes
Wort aber dass man auch sagt ihr
investiert jetzt hin dass ihr euren
Stahl zum Beispiel grün produziert und
wir zahlen das Delta damit eben nicht
der Stahl jetzt aus China oder Südafrika
kommt und da dann eben günstiger aber
für die Umwelt auch teurer hergestellt
wird und dann noch über den Atlantik und
über andere Meere hier bei uns ankommt
wird denn die
gaspreisbremse oder die strompreisbremse
die jetzt in diesem Abwehrschirm da auch
enthalten ist
gesamtvolumenjahr 200 Milliarden Euro
wird die denn in der Lage sein den
konjunkturellen Abschwung den wir jetzt
befürchten was der Wirtschaftsminister
heute ja auch angekündigt hat
abzubremsen ist das ein probates
probates Mittel nein das ist natürlich
in konjunktureller Hinsicht ist das
minimales Strohfeuer was was nichts
ändern kann und ich möchte noch mal ganz
klar sagen ist wir überbrücken damit nur
Schwierigkeiten die Unternehmen und
Bürger haben mit diesen exorbitant
gestiegenen Preisen das kann also
überhaupt gar keine Lösung sein die
Frage ist nur wie lange reichen die 200
Milliarden und dann das nächste Paket
anschieben zu müssen wenn wir keine
Änderung herbeiführen das ist das
entscheidende und die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit ist angesprochen
worden in den USA sind die
Energiekosten zum Beispiel dramatisch
niedriger sind wir uns glaube ich 13 Mal
so hoch wird die Zahlung richtig erklärt
warum das so ist ja zeigen das ist
natürlich ist dramatisch und das
wiederum ruht natürlich auch genau auf
dem was wir über 20 Jahren machen mit
dieser Energiewende die sehr teuer ist
die subventionieren muss und am Ende
nicht funktioniert wir sitzen die sind
auf den Strom entschuldigung ich würde
den Satz genau zu Ende bringen wir sind
auf den Strom auch aus dem Ausland
angewiesen wenn wir die dunkelflaute
haben wie es gibt keine Energiespeicher
wir sind auf angewiesen auf
Kernkraftwerke aus Frankreich was wir
böse finden im eigenen Land atomstrom
ist böse aus Kohlekraftwerken in Polen
gleichzeitig machen wir unsere
Kohlekraftwerke dicht das ist keine
keine verantwortungsvolle Politik sie
haben aber falschschnittlicherweise
gesagt dass der Strompreis hoch ist
wegen der Erneuerbaren Herz Radscha hat
auch schon darauf hingewiesen es gibt
eine Reihenfolge in der Kraftwerke
eingeschaltet werden das billigste ist
derzeit Ökostrom weil sie einfach so
groß geworden sind danach kommt
Braunkohle ich komme ja aus dem
Rheinland vor das rheinische Revier auch
qualmt dass es kracht weil man auch dort
alle Kraftwerke braucht das ist auch
günstige Energie wo sich unsere
Industrie darüber freut dann kommt
Steinkohle dann kommt Atom dann kommt
lange nichts und dann kommt Gas und das
letzte teuerste Kraft der Gesetz den
Preis und das ist Gas deshalb
verabschieden Sie sich von dem Satz
strom ist teuer wegen der Erneuerbaren
das ist falsch das können Sie Ihre
Partei gerne beibringen die
Gaskraftwerke weil die Erneuerbaren
haben das haben wir doch hier heute
abend
Energie ist der günstigste Energie wir
brauchen die Gaskraftwerke um dann wenn
kein Wind weht und keine Sonne scheint
Strom erzeugen zu können deswegen laufen
diese Gaskraftwerke und da sind ja noch
sehr sehr viele geplant die noch kommen
sollen das heißt die Situation wird ja
gar nicht besser aber wir suchen in
anderen Methoden erfolgreich
Energiewende plus Gaskraftwerke für die
Spitzenlast sozusagen wenn wenn wir
nichts haben ist die falsche Politik und
erneuerbare Strom einspeichern es gibt
pumpkraftwerke der Wasserstoff es gibt
andere also natürlich müssen wir doch
die Batterien und das auch miteinander
hier eine speichern großem aus nur weil
das ist jetzt nicht gibt können wir ja
nicht sagen wir werden da nie eine
Lösung finden deswegen machen wir jetzt
einfach Atomen weil dann ist die und
Atom hat übrigens auch keine Wärme und
Atomen kann auch nicht der
Stahlproduzent das ist nämlich Strom
vernünftigen Energie-Mix aber wir
brauchen die grundlastfähigkeit und
kernkraftwerke sind dafür besonders
geeignet weil sie sie verbrauchen
übrigens auch weniger Fläche es ist
wirklich sehr
umweltschutzgrund dafür die hohen
spitzen in der Mittagszeit sind die
Spitze eigentlich zu tun das ist ein
ganz anderes Thema ich glaube sie müssen
einfach ein bisschen energiepolitisches
Grundwissen vermitteln dann ist es
wahrscheinlich so dass alle Länder um
uns rum ziemlich dumm sind dass sie
genau auf diese Technologie setzen als
Brückentechnologie wir sind wieder die
schlausten auf diese auf diesen
politischen Konflikt zurückführen also
es würde doch eine Zeit lang dauern bis
wir ausreichen wenn das jemals
vollständig
erneuerbare Energie haben Gas fällt zum
großen Teil weg wir müssen uns jetzt
eben behelfen um über die nächsten
Winter zu kommen mit Atom und mit Kohle
bei Kohle ist es so dass das ziemlich
klimaschädlich für die Atmosphäre ist
bei Atomkraftwerken klimaschädlich vor
allem für die Ampelkoalition
dieser Hinweis von der neuen also das
heißt wir brauchen ja diese Kohle das
ist konterkariert ja aber eigentlich die
Energiepolitik der Ampelkoalition immer
sagt gut
AKW hätten wir zwar auch noch wollen die
aber nicht weiterführen jedenfalls nicht
über das Frühjahr 2023 hinaus dann
müssen wir uns eben und so ist ja auch
das Credo aus der Ampelkoalition eben
eine Zeit lang ein paar Jahre mit
Kohlekraftwerken behelfen nur um einen
weitgehend emissionsfreies oder eine
weitgehendemissionsfreie Energiequelle
wie Atomkraft zu verhindern aus
politischen Gründen unterstelle ich
jetzt mal ja aber es gibt ja auch im
politischen Grund warum wir damals
ausgestiegen sind weil es ist gefährlich
Herr Professor gesagt das ist teuer es
gibt ja auch keine einzige private
Versicherung die einem ein Atomkraftwerk
versichert weil es eben auch so
gefährlich ist und wir wollen nicht
diese Rolle rückwärts weil wenn wir
jetzt sagen wir machen mal zwei Jahre
dann ist das auch der Weg zum
Wiedereinstieg wir haben andere Ideen wo
wir rein investieren wollen und ja die
Brücke die müssen wir über viele Wege
gehen und die ist auch noch nicht klar
aber wenn wir jetzt nicht diesen Weg
gehen und als Deutschland als
viertstärkste Industrienation als
stärkstes Land in Europa auch vorangehen
und auch diesen Weg zeigen dass wir
dekarbonisieren digitalisieren
Fortschritt in diesem Land schaffen wenn
wir nicht als Tüftler und Denker der das
Land der Siemens und Boss der Volkswagen
und Co wir sind doch gerade
prädestiniert hier jetzt auch eine
Vorreiterrolle einzunehmen und das
machen wir doch ja nochmal zur Atomkraft
sie haben da ja ihre liebe Not jetzt mit
ihrem Koalitionspartner FDP der das
nicht nur Schrecken will der möchte das
mehrere Jahre weiterlaufen lassen auch
das AKW im Emsland das ja angeblich auf
jeden Fall am 31.12 vom Netz gehen soll
ich meine das jetzt auch eher
koalitionspolitisch noch da gibt es ja
eine Menge Schnappatmung in der
Koalition werden sie das hinkriegen oder
scheitert die Ampel an der Atomkraft
daran scheitert die Ampel nicht wir
sitzen in vielen Runden spät früh immer
zusammen
und wir werden uns auch da auf einen Weg
miteinander einigen und wenn Olaf Scholz
eins gezeigt hat dann ist es dass er
gerade der richtige Mann ist für so eine
Konstellation die es ja auch noch nie
auf Bundesebene gab ich komme aus
Rheinland-Pfalz da praktizieren
praktizieren wir das schon sehr
erfolgreich aber eben genau diese
Perspektiven zusammenzuführen zum Wohle
unseres Landes
lassen wir uns nochmal auf die
gaspreisbremse schauen der Professor
Fratzscher da wurde ja das Prinzip
Gießkanne dass dieser Bremse innewohnt
die ja schon im Vorfeld kritisiert jetzt
hat einer der Teilnehmer an dieser
Kommission es ist ja immer noch im
Stadium eines Vorschlags einer
Kommission gesagt ja wir wussten dass
das mit der Gießkanne ein Problem wird
aber da muss Schnelligkeit die Zahl der
Zeitdruck ist hoch vor Genauigkeit gehen
deswegen eben musste diese Gießkanne
sein sie haben das ja auch kritisiert
dieses Gießkannenprinzip aber ist es
nicht tatsächlich so dass der
bürokratische Aufwand um das sozial
gerecht zu machen wenn es überhaupt
möglich ist ewig lange dauert und das
gerade Einzelfallgerechtigkeit in einem
Land wo 80 Millionen Menschen vor dem
Winter zittern eigentlich nicht möglich
ist
das bezweifle ich erstmal muss man
anmerken wenn man eine Schnelligkeit
spricht wieso hat man nicht vor fünf vor
sechs Monaten gehandelt wir wussten vor
fünf bis sechs Monaten dass wir zu
diesem Zeitpunkt kommen würden wo der
Winter kommt und die die Gasrechnungen
die Heizung explodieren werden auch
jetzt ist es ja keine schnelle Lösung
man macht da Abschlagszahlung also die
Gasrechnung wird übernommen im Dezember
aber bis dann wirklich eine dauerhafte
Entlastung kommt ist es März April also
für die nächsten fünf Monate sind die
Menschen bis auf diese Abschlagszahlung
Dezember erst einmal auf sich alleine
gestellt haben zum Teil eine
Verdreifachung der monatlichen
Gasrechnung im Jahresvergleich das heißt
die kommen riesige Kosten vor allem auf
Menschen mit geringen Einkommen zu ist
der erste Punkt also Geschwindigkeit
dass ich als Argument nicht Geld dann
hätte man wirklich vom halben Jahr
agieren müssen zweitens muss man sich
bewusst machen was hier gerade passiert
denn man sagt wir müssen einsparen das
ist eine wichtige Priorität man kann
nicht nur sagen der Staat funktioniert
die Energie sondern wir müssen
mindestens 20 Prozent einsparen der
gaspreisdeckel so wie jetzt gestaltet
ist
schiebt die Last vor allem auf Menschen
mit geringen Einkommen jemand mit einem
Topverdiener mit einer Sauna zu Hause ob
der jetzt 100 oder 200 Euro mehr zahlt
um die Sauna zu mit Gas zu beheizen ist
dem wahrscheinlich nicht so wichtig der
kann sich das leisten aber eine
Rentnerin die mit 1000 oder 1200 Euro im
Monat über die Runden kommen muss die
muss im Prinzip diese deutlich höheren
Kosten die trotz gaspreisbremse auf Sie
zukommen die wird deutlich einsparen
müssen also die Last der Einsparung
liegt vor allem bei den Menschen mit
geringen Einkommen und die Politik hat
auch gezeigt dass sie mit
Einmalzahlungen in den
erstentlastungspakete durchaus Dinge tun
kann sie hat energiepauschalen über
beschäftigte sie hat Rentner neue und
Rentner mit 200 Euro oder 300 Euro extra
gezahlt gleiche bei Studierenden also
ich kaufe das Produkt das Argument nicht
die Bürokratie sei so dysfunktional dass
man Menschen Zielgen entlasten könnte wo
ein politischer Wille ist da muss auch
ein Weg sein deshalb bin ich halte ich
das wirklich für ein vorgeschobenes
Argument ist kann nicht sein das in
einem so modernen Marktwirtschaft ist
nicht gelingt die am stärksten
betroffenen Menschen zielgenau zu
entwickeln wenn jetzt Professor Flasche
die Schnelligkeit als Argument nicht
gelten lässt dann ist es aber eigentlich
ein Vorwurf an die Regierung an die
Bundesregierung vor allen Dingen die
dann offensichtlich die letzten sechs
Monaten gepennt hat noch das glaube ich
gaskommission wurde zu spät eingesetzt
das stimmt und es sie ist auch zu groß
jedes Forschungsinstitut ist da ja
vertreten da wäre auch weniger mehr
gewesen und wenn man schneller zu
Ergebnissen gekommen ja und die
Bundesregierung hat zu spät auf dieses
reagiert und wir es droht das gleiche
sich zu wiederholen wie bei der
gasumlage da hat man ja auch eine Lösung
gefunden dann stelle sich heraus dass
die auch ungerecht ist das plötzlich
ganz viele Firmen zu profitieren drohten
die es gar nicht brauchen hat danach
gebessert und hat sie dann kassiert und
ich schließlich aus dass auch in diesem
ein ähnliches gemurk so passiert und ich
schließe mich Professor Fratzscher an es
wäre auch möglich gewesen über
Einmalzahlungen wie in der corona-zeit
oder bei den Menschen zu helfen man weiß
hier um welche es geht bei dem Wort
pennen haben sie jetzt gerade reagiert
aber er hatte nicht die Ampelkoalition
viel Zeit verplempert jetzt nämlich
jemand anderes Wort verblendert mit
Eitelkeiten zu pflegen die Frage wie wir
damit umgehen wer was bezahlt gibt es
eine Schuldenbremse gibt es keine gibt
es einen steckbetrieb für AKW gibt es
keinen das zieht sich über Wochen seit
dem Sommer hin ist da nicht viel Zeit
verplempert worden also geschlafen hat
keiner wir haben viele Pakete auf den
Weg gebracht und ich möchte mal eins
sagen wir entlasten ja gerade auch die
Menschen mit den geringen Einkommen aber
die gaspreisbremse ist nicht
Sozialpolitik da haben wir andere Ideen
wie zum Beispiel eine große
wohngeldreform wo zwei Millionen
Menschen da werde ich morgen zu im
Plenum reden können alle mal
reinschalten das wird Phoenix gerade
sagen
die geringverdienenden
heizkomponente die dauerhaft ist das
werden zwei Millionen Menschen sein das
sind insbesondere Alleinerziehende da
muss ich ja jetzt nicht an der
Gasrechnung drehen sondern da haben wir
auch andere Ideen wahrscheinlich 15 bis
20 Millionen Haushalte die entlastet
werden müssen sie haben völlig Recht am
unteren Ende aber das kann sich über was
anderes aber hier geht zum Energie hier
geht es um die gerade geht es ganz
konkret darum wie bezahlen die Leute
ihre Gasheizung ihre Gasrechnung im
Winter ihre Heizung und wir haben jetzt
für ein vier Personenhaushalt die bisher
1200 € im Monat im Jahr hatten an
Rechnung das geht auf über 4000 Euro das
kommt die gaspreisbremse die bringt das
runter ungefähr auf ja vielleicht 2700
Euro es bleiben aber noch 1500 Euro mehr
und ich rede jetzt nicht über die
Menschen die Heizkosten Zuschuss ziehen
oder die Wohngeld beziehen sondern
Menschen die arbeiten die wenig
verdienen und die sich diese
zusätzlichen Kosten einfach nicht
leisten können und da kommen wir in eine
riesige soziale Schieflage und das sind
die Menschen die getroffen sind und die
dann wirklich den länger schnallen
müssen also die einspannen müssen weil
sie sich eben diese 1500 Euro nicht
leisten können also ist eine zu höchst
unsoziale gaspreisbremse so wie sie
ausgestein ein Gedanke wo jeder einzelne
egal wie sozial oder wirtschaftlich
situiertes mithelfen kann wäre ja das
Sparen das Einsparen setzt denn holen
diese gaspreisbremse wie sie jetzt
konzipiert ist im Dezember gibt es eine
einmalige Abschlagszahlung und dann soll
ab März oder April sollen 80 Prozent
eines bestimmten Verbrauchs
subventioniert werden setzt diese
gaspreisbremse auch einen sparanreiz
sparanreizt ja das denke ich schon das
ist schon hilfreich das war ja bei der
Konstruktion eigentlich das schwierige
dass das sozusagen hinzubekommen dass
das dieser sparrenreiz erhalten bleibt
und so wie das aussieht ist das auch so
geschaffen das kann man denke ich so
machen man muss natürlich auch sehen
dass wieder einige Leute außen vor
bleiben nach jetzigem Stand das ist ja
alles noch nicht abgeschlossen aber nach
jetzigem Stand ist es so das
beispielsweise diejenigen die mit Öl
oder Pellets heißen heizen eben nicht
Unterstützung bekommen dass gerade
unternehment habe man kann sich
irgendwie einrichten gerade Unternehmen
das müssen wir auch natürlich jetzt mal
deutlich in den Fokus stellen es gibt
viele Unternehmer die keinen neuen
Gasvertrag bisher bekommen haben weil
natürlich die versorge auch nicht so
richtig wissen wie sie kalkulieren
sollen also sehr sehr schwierig das
Problem und die wissen gar nicht wie es
weitergeht und
können sozusagen jetzt von der
gaspreisbremse erstmal gar nichts
erwarten es sei denn da gibt es dann
noch eine Regelung also die Dinge müssen
auf jeden Fall noch auf den Tisch um da
diese Lösung
aber sie als Vertreter der
Ampelkoalition Frau Roberts hier das
über ist ja noch ein Vorschlag der
Energie in einer Expertenkommission
diese gaspreisbremse wird die
Bundesregierung die Koalition und damit
auch die Parlamentsmehrheit das so etwa
1 zu 1 übernehmen was wir jetzt wissen
ich habe es ja gerade skizziert was
Inhalt dieser gaspreisbremse sein soll
nein und das ist auch gut so denn wir
haben das Parlament und wir sind der
Gesetzgeber und die Kommission hat in
einer Schnelligkeit Vorschläge
erarbeitet natürlich hat die einen
gewissen bindenden Charakter aber genau
um diese Detailfragen was ist mit den
Menschen die eine Ölheizung haben ab
wann müssen wir da mal dran denken wie
gehen wir jetzt auch in der exekutiven
Umsetzung um also da ist jetzt jede
Menge für uns zu tun und deswegen ist
das jetzt hier nicht eins zu eins ins
Gesetzblatt zu drucken und die gasbremse
hat nicht genug Anreiz zu sparen leider
nicht schon bei den Preisen hohen
Preisen die wir jetzt haben sparen die
Leute ja nicht genug und auch wenn wir
nicht alles subventionieren sondern nur
ein Teil ist der Effekt ist zu fürchten
zu gering deshalb ja die Netzagentur
auch noch mal eindringlich gewarnt hat
Leute spart es hat natürlich Anreize zu
sparen aber ich ausreichend
hauptsächlich für die Menschen die wenig
haben und sich einfach auch diese 1500
extra nicht also das ist ja die
Verteilung es ist werden die Menschen
sparen müssen die am wenigsten haben
aber auch am wenigsten verbrauchen und
am wenigsten Euro bekommen mehr Menschen
mit hohen Einkommen haben ein viermal
höheren energiever Vergleich zu Menschen
mit geringen Einkommen dies kann er
heißt die bekommen auch viermal so viel
in Euro wie Menschen mit geringen
Einkommen aber jemand mit wenig
Einkommen jeder 100 Euro mehr heißt die
müssen massiv sparen nicht nur beim beim
Heizen sondern eben auch bei anderen
Dingen deshalb wird sich die soziale
Schieflage noch mal verschärfen und
diese gaspreisbremse ist letztlich eine
unverteilung von unten nach oben das
wird bei den Konflikten und in vielen
Diskussionen auch zum Teil erbittert
geführten in den nächsten Wochen und
Monaten bleiben das Resümee auch dieser
Sendung ich bedanke mich bei Verena
Huppertz bei Antje Höning bei liveeric
Holm und bei Marcel Fratscher Liebe
ZuschauerInnen liebe Zuschauer morgen in
der Phönix Runde kritische Infrastruktur
im Visier was stärkt unsere Abwehr
moderiert von Anke Plettner jetzt bei
Phoenix der Tag mit Konstanzer platzki
unter anderem noch mal ein Blick auf die
Pressekonferenz von Robert Habeck zur
Herbstprojektion zur Voraussage der
Wirtschaft Entwicklung der nächsten
Monate und auch noch über den Rücktritt
des rheinland-pfälzischen Minister
Entschuldigung Innenministers
roga Lebens erst zurückgetreten wegen
der Verantwortung die jetzt übernimmt
für die Flutkatastrophe im Aartal im
vergangenen Jahr bleiben Sie bei uns